what an absolute gem of a game 400 yards
passing
for kyler murray 300 yards passing for
jalen hurts who also
ran one in himself just a dynamite game
that was even more enjoyable because of
who was calling it
uh brandon got uh gaudine of uh fox was
on the play by play
and then at the uh at the mic uh
providing the analysis uh who suit put
the uh color in color commentary
uh the one and only akib talib here on
the rich eisen show how are you sir
rich what's going on it's always a
pleasure are you aware that your
your your commentary and the way that
you were going about your business
was just lighting up uh twitter social
media and uh
everybody's ear gates across the country
were you aware of that during the game
yeah you know i
i i check it i check it uh post game
real quick mk on my way to the airport
but you know i'm not too big on social
networks so
you know i don't pay too much attention
to it rich but you were great
yeah you you have been great and you
were great and you had a huge game that
put
uh put so many people's attention on
your
on your analysis what is your philosophy
i mean seriously what what
i i i know being yourself is is is not
easy in this business but
honestly what is your philosophy when
you're putting that headset on in your
new foundation
i think that's exactly it rich i'm just
having fun
uh talking about the game that i love so
i'm just enjoying it rich i ain't trying
to be nobody
that i'm not you know what i'm saying if
fox didn't want our kids to leave on the
show they wouldn't put our key to leave
on the show so
you know it's not hard to tell who i
came to leave is so
if you want him on the show you expect
him to be yourself so i just be myself
have fun and
they keep me around the game rich i love
football i mean i absolutely love
football uh just to have to study the
game
and be able to watch it from that
perspective it's different for me
i feel like a rookie all over again well
and it's not just you being you akeeb
you were just
speaking your mind you know you were you
were saying what was on your mind
and sometimes you know you got to break
some eggs to make the omelet
and let me get into this uh do you think
carson wentz's tenure in philadelphia
is over based on what you saw from jalen
hurts yesterday oh man
oh man rich based on on what i've seen
watching watching leading up to the game
you know just watching them come in
against green bay watching this first
start versus new orleans
and then watching them live versus
cardinals i think it's over for carson
he's too good he's too good uh i think
management
in philadelphia is going to fall in love
with him just doing interviews with him
and talking to him me and brandon was
like
you sound like a 15-year vet and it's
you here to hit you hear his teammates
and his coaches rave about him
and then you meet him and talk to him
and you see why he sounded like a
10-year vet
he's so calm he's so poised and so
confident in himself and
and it's not a cocky confidence it's a
real leader i've been around great
leaders it's a real
leader under center over there in philly
so i think i think quarterback play
starts with your play but but you also
have to be a great leader
so i think man he's checking all the
boxes and i think it's his job to lose
yeah i mean we had you know on game day
morning on nfl network yesterday akib
and you know you've been on that set
with us
and you know everybody does tell it like
you like it is michael irvin was saying
look when miles sent when he heard miles
sanders say after the game against the
saints
that the minute jalen hurts hit the
huddle and he had full command of it and
that was exactly
quote unquote what we needed he's like
oh he doesn't think wence could ever
step back in that huddle and obviously
that
and that was just after one game and i
know that's kind of a knee-jerk reaction
but what i saw yesterday i don't know
how
the eagles ever go back to the the
before
akiba yeah you know i don't think they
go back rich i think
i think carson somehow finds his way
back to frank wright
you know with phillip phillip being up
there in the years phillip won't be
there forever even though he's having a
great season
and rejuvenated season but i think
carson somehow
ends up in indy and he's happy philly is
happy
but i think jalen is definitely the new
guy in town man the new face of that
franchise
he deserves it i keep talib here uh
fresh off of calling the eagles and
cardinals yesterday and lighting up
television screens across the country
right here on the rich eisen show
what about kyla murray uh how did you
find him
when you talked to him watched him and
uh now this team is eight and six and it
does appear
uh a win if not maybe two away from
getting
the arizona cardinals back in the
playoffs what about him
uh the same the same rich man
we always talk about our league being in
great hands with these quarterbacks and
i got to see two of them live yesterday
rich two
two bright stars two future stars of our
league
uh tyler man and that arizona cardinals
team is so dangerous
they they they've been even during their
losing streak i mean
three four plays away from scoring 40 so
many times
and they just so dangerous if they can
not turn the ball over two times in the
red zone that's easily a 40 point game
same last week against the giants you
know they convert on a couple
you know fourth downs in the red zone
but uh that dangerous team
they got they got a great rush great
pass rush two good corners who could
play man
and uh great run game when kyler when
kyler uses legs man they
they might be one of the most dangerous
teams in the nfc so
whoever at that two seed look out rich
look out cause this is
a it's a real it's gonna be a real shock
when uh arizona comes down
it could be if they keep that seven
seats and it could be new orleans you
know
it could be green bay it could be uh
either one of those two teams that we're
looking at right now
now then um i i know you covered both of
these guys
and this is the good thing that that
that kylie's got a goat in larry
right um and then uh an emerging goat
uh in deandre hopkins uh you know
it's it's amazing he he gets his feet
down every time and then this the
touchdown that we're showing right now
on the screen
where he grabbed a ball with one hand
and
made twisted his body to get in the end
zone past the pylon and then when he hit
the ground
there was no question he was going to
just keep it gripped with one hand
and it wouldn't come loose no there's
nobody and i know that there's so many
great receivers in the game
there really is nobody like him aki
would you agree with that or
you could agree with that and it's not
he's not the fastest it almost seems
like he's not even playing full speed at
times but
his body control and his knowledge of
the game if you play his own courage he
knows exactly where to go
and if you play man coverage he knows
exactly where to put his body
and so kyle so colin murray can throw
the ball and he's in a good position to
catch it
so i think man his body control in his
hands
his ball skills are second to none in
the league
this would be another all-pro uniform
and uh
he's he's definitely he at the beginning
of the year he might not have been in my
top five
i don't know why i just you know i
always lean towards faster receivers and
say who i really like but from watching
him
studying really the last four or five
games he played
hop is definitely in my top three now
rich man he's he's an amazing receiver
you you when you really study him you
see some of the things he brings to the
table
and uh he's definitely in my top three
now in the league and dangerous receiver
and
like he said he's going to be a future
hall of famer another r pro team that
another all-pro season for him that'll
be four in a row i believe
and uh beat your hall of famer like you
said rich
who would be tougher to cover akib to
liebs somebody who is
a physical beast like deandre hopkins
who you say
is well versed on where to go with man
where to go with zone how to use his
body
has full control of his body when you
know the sideline might not even be your
friend defending him
uh or somebody who is now five
touchdown receptions away from joining
randy moss
and jerry rice is the only members of
the 20
touchdown club in a single season in
tyreek hill who's tougher
to cover do you think i think i think i
think tyree got pretty good ball skills
too so
he's not just no and he's a pretty smart
player when it comes to man and zone too
because uh he put he put pressure on you
and patrick holmes patrick mahomes he
makes you learn what to do in those zone
coverages so
i would say tyrique just because he's
blazing that speed is different rich
it's not like no other receiver in the
league
uh is is you would be surprised by that
speed once you line up in front of it
look one way on tv but once
you're the person lined up in front of
you you're definitely going to be
surprised by that speed
he's amazing well i definitely he should
definitely say tyrique maybe
maybe a harder couple cover isn't that
amazing because
and we just sung hopkins praises
rightfully so i mean his
catch radius is insane his ability to to
leap over
you know a triple team is insane but
tyree kill is
becoming maybe the best receiver in the
game would you
how do you rank him and everyone else
right now
yeah definitely i i you know i only
could speak in terms of
for me to cover it right that's that's
i'm only in my shoes
i see the world not these guys so i only
can speak for me so for me
tyrique will be a tough recovery and uh
i definitely i think he is the best in
the league i like tyrek
i like dk i like devonte and i like hot
now after after yesterday shining live
hop is now my number three so
i if i was a if i was a franchise owner
and and i had him saying three ticks at
receiver i could pick my top three
i'll probably go tyrique here dk
and ha i might go to m3
and and and the close and the close and
if i go if i if i called a green bay
game
and i had to study uh devonta adams he
would probably move into my top three so
you know that that's in the change with
devonta adams up there too
he is amazing and again we're going to
see him on sunday night football on nbc
with against the titans a a big game
uh akeeb talib here on the rich eisen
show you have more games left this
season next two weeks
do you have any more is that there well
the deal i did was foxy kind of you know
they
they kind of tell me as they go so i
didn't know i didn't know i had last
game until about eight days before the
game no 10 days before the game
so hopefully i do hopefully i do they
say something about week 17 maybe
okay hopefully i do man i enjoy it we
gotta get you back
in the booth oh you you you have to be
let's be honest you have to be
and now uh we get to what everybody's
talking about as well
more than just uh your game and what
you're talking about is what you're
wearing
uh let's give a shout out to the suit um
and uh and so first off uh walk me
through the
the process the suit process for you
akeeb and how you chose yesterday's suit
uh i i i go through uh elevate or
i mean i'm still not sure i've been
dealing with them for 12
13 years now and i'm still not sure how
to say the name
or lab one of them but uh
has been doing my suit since 2008 shout
out to chandra from lfa
and uh i just told her that you know
it's christmas time maybe something
festive
she was like boom i got the perfect
perfect little cloth for you
what you think about this i'm like
trying to do your thing and you know we
collaborated on the shoes there was a
louboutin
collaborated on the shoes and uh man she
always gets me together man she does a
great job
she does suits for everybody larry
fitzgerald bob miller
uh michael thomas he does suits for so
many people
and she do a great job at it man so i
said
festive and she made it festive so i
like it
i would agree it is absolutely festive
it's christmas time red red tie and then
the
the green check look right here now what
is your philosophy
uh i've been around dion uh dion says he
wears a suit on television once and he's
got to retire it for three years
because he doesn't want to look in the
same what is your philosophy now
like when would the next time be that we
would ever see you in this particular
suit
okay definitely definitely won't see me
in this suit like
ever again maybe it may be i'm saying
one and done if i did something
locally next christmas i may do
something but
i'm like prom though once once once it
make ways
it's pretty much retired it's over with
so
luckily i'm fortunate enough to be if
it's another event i'm fortunate enough
to be able to buy another suit you know
so it's pretty much retired man i play i
play the same as prom
in the closet so yeah it's maybe next
time maybe just the top maybe i might
switch it up just the top you know
switch the ties switch to pocket square
yeah something like that but
accessories the whole suit christmas
vibe it's probably over with for that
okay
one and done but hopefully not in the
booth i'm telling you akeeb it was great
it was so much fun listening to you
i was saying earlier today uh when peter
king was talking about it as well we
were talking about your
your your uh style and your
your clear-eyed and clear-voiced
uh analysis that i felt like i was in
fact sitting next to a player watching
the game like it was that simple and i
have been you know as you know
you've seen the the process by which we
watch games at nfl network pre-pandemic
but it sounded like you were just
sitting there as a former player just
telling it like it is
like you were seeing it that was great
and that's and that's what i try to do
that's what i try to do
honestly i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
honest with you rich yep i tried i tried
to play football right i'm playing
football so
i started liking cornerbacks so i
started watching the best who the best
who's the best i started watching dion
so you know i started trying to mimic
what he do
play how he plays do at the start of the
play i want my fans to look like his
so i started trying to mimic the best
because i want to be the best so
honestly when i started doing this fox
stuff i listen to tony romo who makes
the most money in this business
tony i listen to tony romo tony romo
sounds the same it sounds like he's
having fun
him and gymnast sister and they watch
the game
and he just he he fill you in with
information when he feels like it's
necessary besides that he's just
you know calling the game telling you
what happened and and he's having fun
you know what i'm saying so i just try
to do it like tony man
i try to go like tony do it and just
have fun sit there call it hot seat
don't try to be nobody else but myself
that's what tony does so
he makes the most money in this business
so right now he's the best
that's why i watch rich i love that
that's not a bad guy to model yourself
after both professionally and
financially there's no doubt about that
and yeah it was there any rookie hazing
on uh for you uh did anybody uh or
is there anything like that nah no ricky
hayes there's five five rich gross rich
gross over at fights they
ain't got me with the rookie hazing yet
okay but uh maybe if i maybe if i got a
real deal with him i'm saying i was
really fine to him
maybe that stuff would start happening
here well akeeb uh i could not be uh
pounding the table for more games from
you
any louder than i am right now i
appreciate the two cents right here and
let's do this and when the playoffs hit
uh i'd love to have you on let's uh
let's now uh let's do some analysis
i'd love for you to call in and tell
everybody what you think about the games
that are
just been played and previously the
upcoming ones i'd love to keep doing
this with you
it'd be great say no more rich let's do
it uh had a guy
set it up i'm available you got it let's
do it akeeb congrats on that big game
yesterday let's talk down the line happy
holidays
merry christmas to you and yours happy
holidays rich i'll take care you bet
that's a keem to leave right here
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here